okay good morning everyone we have a
really nice program my session for the
morning and the first talk this morning
is by Custis and the stuff sein and his
talk is what electric too hard to tell
us about the brain thank you thank you
for them like Bartlett last time we I
was in Berkeley was 2001 and was part of
a road trip as Europeans you know
traveling back and up and down
California and so I don't remember it
being so nice something must have
happened
Simon's foundation has been great to you
so yeah this is the title of my talk or
the title III thought was a good idea to
present about a few weeks back but and
the motivation between this talk has to
do with the two layers of what sort of
understanding the brain code on the one
side we have them you know brain signals
such as you know calcium signals
electrophysiology signals all sort of
signals and then on the left-hand side
we have the computation or the the brain
code and somehow we try to go back you
know from from right to left and so my
team's sort of work at the Allen
Institute but also when I was back at
Caltech with Christoph was to basically
connect the two dots and basically what
our approach or how we went about it was
to try to understand the detailed
biophysics of neurons and and networks
and the reason for that is that it's
those detailed biophysics that both give
rise to the observables in an experiment
it synapses your
and networks doing something at the same
time it's the same by physics they give
rise to the code and so so far our work
was very much motivated by understanding
this to the extent that I would argue
that for my work without understanding
how a code is manifested in the brain
makes it very hard to actually
understand the code so I think I know
and we've done a lot of work with
experiments and theory trying to bridge
between the three levels of abstraction
if you wish but yesterday I decided I
don't want to necessarily talk about all
these electric fields and and how they
specifically relate to the code because
I was very motivated by the presentation
I'm by Burberry Sherman and so I decided
I want to I want to present something
different and so at the AL and we do
have we are focusing our on cortical
circuits especially in the visual
pathway of the mouse and so when we look
at this canonical diagrams but we
accidentally introduced yesterday the
one thing that stands out here is this
beautiful layer five pyramidal neuron
that has all this intricate connections
to actually all layers of cortex and or
a column if you wish as well as thalamus
obviously and it's actually the layer
five pcs that have the ability to not
just affect intra cortical computations
but also project back to thalamus right
and so that gives them a lot of power
and our our we were motivated to
understand how they behave or what kind
of computations that can perform in
order for us actually to understand a
little bit better
vision and the coding during vision and
so basically my talk today is going to
be about the electrophysiology setup of
layer 5 permanently runs in Mouse g1 the
computation the computations enabled
this EFA's setup and then I'm gonna
introduce a little bit of some of other
thoughts we have to what X about how we
would like to go about to move from the
mouse to the human code if you wish so
I'll start with the EFA's setup of layer
5 Mouse v1 neurons and a lot of work
actually has been done in this layer 5
and pyramidal neurons we have one of the
primary investigators of that cell type
here and and so but we back a few years
back
specifically with mouse v1 they were not
so well understood or they have not been
explaining study in rats and
somatosensory cortex so we'd like to
we'd like to us that it a bit more at
what extent some of the principles that
hold it some in primer so my sense your
areas actually translate into the mouse
and mouse for you one and this is work
done primarily by Adam shy and so this
is basically a vanilla version of the
kraken experiment where we have
channelrhodopsin expressed in a whole
bunch of different areas feed-forward as
well as feedback and basically we have
axons or Adam had axons projecting to
this single layer 5 pyramidal cell in
Mouse v1 basically expressing
channelrhodopsin and the whole reason
I'm showing you this is that so here
what these traces show is the kind of
somatic depolarization you get when you
shine light in each of these pixels and
close to the soma or the person
area which is associated with
feed-forward inputs you shine light you
get a somatic depolarization and that
makes sense the reason I show this is
that actually then comes a zone where
you see nothing or not much
depolarization and then very far out in
the tuft there's still a second zone
where if you generate or you shine light
all of a sudden you get somatic
depolarizations from these far away
terminals now as actually shown by
Bartlett a month ago based on passive at
least their dendrites this shouldn't be
happening you should not be able to get
any signal from up here down here based
on chapter 4 by physics of computation
so the idea is then that there's
something happening there's some active
mechanism that is able to get these
synapses activated up here and push the
charge down to the soma and of course as
we know from layer 5 primarily urns in
in in in rat cells these kinds of events
have been mainly attributed to calcium
channels in there a pin there and the
apical dendrites and so basically and
together with Matthew Larkin we started
we wanted to basically try to understand
a little bit better about how this
calcium events affect that the coding in
this layer 5 pyramidal cells so here's
that a typical soma dendritic patch
experiment by single layer 5 PC and
basically what you see here is the fact
that when you depot when you inject the
DC current one second at the dendrite
it's fairly close to the soma so 150
microns away you get these very nice
standardized action potentials at the
soma here in black that then actually
also propagate up and can also be
measured by this electrode here shown in
red now interestingly when you take this
pipette and you push it much higher up
in the tuft and you do precisely the
same kind of current injection what you
get is a very very different response at
the soma as well as locally at the
dendrites basically what you see is this
huge 100 150 millisecond long
depolarizations that and then basically
you go from individual spiking to burst
spike bursts these again black here is a
somatic transient red here is shown what
is recorded here at the local dendritic
pipette and here you really see this
huge events going on right and so
obviously what's going on here is that
you know somehow there is the zone
around 300 or 400 microns away in this
layer 5 pyramidal cells that all of a
sudden if you put enough charge in it
turns on and gets you from a fairly
standardized spiking mode to a burst
mode and this is important because the
hypothesis is that bursts are much more
informative for downstream areas
compared to their regular spiking
on a second experiment now the question
is okay so when we inject locally at the
dendrites current it can travel down a
court and get and generate a different
kind of spiking at the soma at the same
time we know that when we generate
action potentials at the soma those
travel back it's called the back
propagating action potential and there
is an additional interesting finding
there that if you J if one generates
standardized spiking at the soma those
travel down in a pretty standardized way
once the current injections start
basically inducing much faster spiking
at the soma you get a back propagating
action potential but on top of a bolus
of activity seen here and this actually
slow depolarization again is also at is
also attributed to those calcium events
which is interesting because what that
means is from that in an injection at
the soma you have an event that
depending on how fast fighting happens
travels up causes a nonlinear event at
the dendrite that then travels back down
and is seen at the somatic after
depolarization so we knew that that sort
of thing can happen and again in rad
cells we want to test to what extent
they also happen in Mouse 4u1 and this
is called the critical frequency
experiment and what you see here is that
indeed slow spiking at forty Hertz so
triplets at forty Hertz cause these
nicely basically standardized responses
as soon as we increase the frequency of
the triplet you gets this huge after
depolarization events that are basically
assigned or attributed it to this
calcium events then then travel back
down and this is the quantification of
that that
with a critical frequency in this
particular case being around 90 Hertz
for this particular neuron now these are
very complicated events and so we have a
back propagating action potential we
have a nonlinear calcium event we have
synapses obviously both at the far end
of the dendrites of the tuft as well as
close to the soma so how does this all
work together and so in order to address
these questions we went ahead and build
a simulation that was and this isn't by
physically detailed simulation that is
able to account for these effects that I
showed you before
basically that calcium events generated
by the father the close versus the far
electrode and in this particular model
this calcium events action and the
experiments are able to create also this
burst mode which is important for the
coding aspects of these particular cell
type as I'll show you in a bit so long
story short here we have a model that
replicates the basic findings of the
experiments and so the question is then
okay so if you have now a simulation
like this what what can you say about
the life of a neuron in in under
realistic conditions and so in order to
do to address this question basically
what we did was to take out all these
pipettes because they're not typically
in our brains and substituted with
synapses and based on the experiments
that I showed you we wanted to look at
specifically excitatory synapses versus
close vs. further away up in the tuft
and try to see what kind of modes of
computations can this neuron support
give an interplay of these different
synapses in different places and so we
show that when we activate close to the
soma
basil dendrites we basically get the
single spike over neuron at the soma
I'd say again read is that dendritic
voltage the dendritic voltage okay and
basically not much is happening except
that single spike you now activate on
the other hand only the the tuft and
what you see is that then really nothing
happens right so but what happens if you
activate both basil and tuft but you
then see is these very nonlinear
response that all of a sudden that and
same neuron the same now - turn up says
all of a sudden turned into burst mode
right which is very different from this
in single spike and we were able to
establish
we were able to establish that this is
in indeed due to this calcium hot zone
up here because when we reduced the
concentration of calcium channels up
here again you go into the single spike
mode so you need these non-linearity at
the dendrites to get into the burst mode
and basically we're also able to show
that this holds also when there is a
hyperpolarization at the soma with this
more greater effect actually shown both
at the at the soma as well as a the
dendrite now so the simulation suggests
that there is this interesting interplay
between feed-forward and feedback and
put our basal versus apical input that
gets you these this particular cell type
in different kinds of of spike modes
right and the question is though okay
this is basically the the simulation
where I'm showing you just this spike
frequency output of this when I talk
about spike frequency I'll put a bit I
mean somatic spikes and you see that you
know up to once once a certain amount of
synapses get Co activated at the but the
basal apical dendrites you get into this
burst mode if you only have feet forward
so basal inputs you
these individual spikes slower things
happening if you only get tuft inputs to
some extent nothing happens right the
calcium channels inactivate yes yes so
so so absolutely and all I'm talking
about is the first instance so the
critical frequency ik so calcium events
can be activated for certainly you know
20 30 40 second experiments because I'm
talking about the critical expert
critical frequency experiments and there
they go from Triplets
slow to fast right and all of a sudden
you get this this this fast activation
right and that also depends on their
only conditions of the solution so it
would it would mean seconds right and
there and there's actually protocols to
do that faster so that I don't know if
they apply in the brain in the first
thing
yes so so so burst of the same neuron is
at least in terms of cortex not exactly
a super frequent event right so normally
you have you know individual cell the
individual cells spiking at one half or
one-and-a-half herds then a little
sudden they get hit right this little
normal spike distribution that you're
talked about so often you're bisciotti
sorry um I think it was 2004 Walters
send and a few Larkin had a paper kind
of they were using current injections in
the Tufts and their argument with the it
basically gradually steepened the FI
curve that the which would be sort of
like the response to the Basel in little
loan and you know kind of in a grated
way increase the gain of the cell I'm
not so I'm trying to figure out Turkey
to reconcile this with that are they
capable or are they different results so
again in an our case the limitation if
you want is that we looked at the first
that what we what we cared about is only
that first burst or the initial burst
condition right we would not look so
vaulter then looks at the most longer
kind of time effects with the learning
rules right that's that's a slightly
different mode of operation but III what
I would argue though is that the
principles I'm sort of like about to
present are more general and are not
mutually exclusive so so the idea then
is like alright so we have this complex
thing sorry oh yeah going back and forth
and then the question is alright so what
does this mean in terms of computation
and so we wanted to see whether so you
have this two different zones right you
have the local soma and you have the
apical dendrite and you can look at them
as to individual spiking zones and then
the question is all right so what
captures what conceptual representation
captures these two of the activity of
these two zones better
and we found so we tried the typical
multiplicative and additive models and
we found that while they were applicable
for certain zones that did not do as
good of a job as a composite function
waveform and then of course the question
becomes what is this what does that mean
right and so what that means or what
this this conceptual model says is that
in fact that neuron Laurel a five pcs
basically respond to basal input and
that the job of the apical dendrites or
the feedback is to lower the threshold
of this spiking right so once they're
activated the threshold is lowered so
these layer five neurons are more prone
to spike and the spike output grows so
and in fact we we sort of test it and
once the calcium zoom calcium Watson was
taken out this composite way from with
its predictions it terior ated so the
calcium hot zone is required to see
basically this effect here so what that
means is that this is the spike output
of the so much function of the basal
input what it means is that the basal
input gets you in this area here as soon
as though as the apical input kicks in
that lowers the threshold push you to
the left and grows their amplitude
alright so basically you change it
basically you can see it as as image as
a gain modulation for there for the
sigmoid so that means lowering of the
spike threshold yeah you don't go up you
go down and so then the question becomes
alright - what is this
why is this good for her vision at all
and so this is actually we tested these
different models by basically feeding
them in a phone Mises distribution with
varying compression and long story short
what we found is that this composite
waveform what it allows you to do is for
a tie it tighter orientation selectivity
as function of the office of an
individual input so basically it's
easier to tune these layer 5 pyramidal
neurons when they have these you know
feed for and feedback activities as
opposed if you don't have them and so
but this is you know just this was a
prediction based on the models that you
know then of course we had a Michael
hoisters paper with Spencer Smith let
showed data in vivo where this actually
holds where actually you take out these
calcium events and vivo you see that
orientation tune and get lost in in in
in this layer five pcs and so the final
thing I want to say if I have a minute
is that okay so but then these this this
mechanism as we heard yesterday we
talked to it you know there was a
discussion about acting you know active
calcium events yesterday also marked
implied is active events in CA one so it
seems to be a more generalized mechanism
around which you know begs the question
okay so what what is this to zone
activation good for in a general
perspective and this is where I think
Matthews ideas are very interesting
where he claims that this could be a
cellular mechanism for cortical
associations so basically the feedback
or the input to the tuft could be an
internal reproduction or internal
representation of a concept
and the feed-forward input into the
basal dendrites could be something like
sensory input and that what these layer
five pyramidal neurons allow you to do
is actually compare sense your input to
their a presentation and one certain
feedly certain features are there so
there's some feature completion just
back propagating action potential
together with their calcium events allow
you to go allows it's specific cell type
to go into this new burst mode which
means obviously maximally informative
for the projection neurons I don't want
to go into this I'm more than happy to
discuss it afterwards so your first
slide is a cracking slide yeah they're
inputs there where from lateral medial
abstracted description of what these two
your first slide is an experiment that
addresses exactly what the elements are
what are that come to basal versus it or
are they different wherever is it from
and you do they match what you're trying
to put was here so that experiment
wanted to show that although you have
inputs going up in the tuft right you
can see them at the soma so that there's
an active make I understand that that
was the point that you're making
but that experiment explicitly allows
you to determine the origin of inputs of
different processes favorite tree right
and yeah and then I don't see how that
is how you can solve this kind of hand
wavy model with a Krakken experiment
they are but I mean in this particular
case though you would have math you
think of the cons of a purse of a
concept like a tiger right and now you
need to you have basically these
Association pattern completion kind of
mechanism and I think that it's hard to
show beyond biophysics in a slice
experiment
so actually Matthew has done a lot of
such work in vivo right in s1 suggesting
these kind of mechanisms maybe
are you taking questions no I'm trying
to finish but I was supposed to finish
five minutes ago yes ooh
human brain I don't know we also do
human brain at the Allen Institute so we
want to see from so we get this we want
to ask to what extent some of the single
neuron models or some similar setups are
present also in the human brain we
always assume that they are that's what
we use all these rodents but it's not
exactly clear that they are and so we're
pursuing this line of work at the Allen
where we get tissue brain tissue from
epilepsy patients and then we have the
court facility to you know standard use
the standardized protocols do the
reconstructions and then we whip the
computer by some of their methods you
know develop a first developed by show
and then we get at least the single new
models that can get us go in starting
these questions or addressing these
questions that we already asking in
their rodent and with that I need a
person back yeah there's an opening
right now so for all the talented
postdocs or near postdocs if you're
interested let me know and yes so
special thanks to Adam obviously Matthew
and Christoph and but also especially
the last part of the work is involves a
whole bunch of people at the Institute
so and of course the Paul Allen for use
generosity so thank you for your
attention
now the question
the organizers told me I could be a
little bit plastic so maybe we can take
two quick like what's in UPS yeah so
there's a different way of thinking
about computational modeling the role in
these circuits so one is just what are
the certain one of the neurons doing in
some sort of generic way so being a
gamma coder if I see birth it's just
it's four phase lucky Oh done so I want
to be talked out of that second point
would be honey get this signal from the
distal dendrites to this summer hmm okay
so when when I see your work I think
okay maybe there's a way of turning the
lights on back there so that the signal
can get through end of story but it but
to see to think that you could take the
biophysical properties of these cells
and and map them in some raw ponies away
aren't a function is is very ambitious
but then I have another word and so what
I will not claim is that there are no
assumptions there are you will be able
to capture everything so in those by
physical simulations that there you know
the disk or developed to ask these
questions of course there was a bias
it's two into like alright so we're
interested in this wind and that we
think this important thing that is
important it's always I mean for us it's
informative about you know quantifying
certain things making a stable
hypothesis and then going back into the
experiment and showing them and so as
much as I'd like to say oh you know
there's the simulation and we've
included everything in it I showed them
very you know next to the experiments
because I don't believe the simulations
exist without the experiments you have
to have some sort of hypothesis that
you're testing right that because as you
said you're never going to be able to
get everything you know exactly right
and I into some case I mean Bartlett has
been I mean doing this work for a long
time I'd say and and I don't know to
what extent do you think there
how much detail versus how you know how
much abstraction is required to you know
address a question as always as balance
that was driving but don't assume that I
said simulation is the only thing for it
in fact 95% of the budget of the Allen
is not simulation no it's just one quick
finish I mean in silicon we have all
these abstraction levels so we have the
micro card and assembly and supply blah
blah life and so long before we could
get to a program that we can actually
understand in terms of intelligent
thought we have to go through these
layers and that it just seems that that
is when when you started talking I
thought we were gonna be down in the
engine room where we in sort of some
somehow turn these complicated
biophysical units into some abstraction
that would not be tied to what they do
but just made them appreciated
appreciated we can go down to the engine
room with a question yeah maybe we
should take it to the Koffee because
that's a longer one I learned something
from I think it was Matthew Larkin
listen talk then surprise me and I just
want to have you help help me understand
this so layer one we think of it as the
tuft as being a place that receives
input that somehow modulate or you said
feedback you know people have always
spoken of it as a module Ettore input
and you are showing oh you know when you
activate the tough it increases the or
it makes it easier for the cell
degenerative bursts so it's sort of a
gained increasing saying a threshold
lowering thing again it feels a lot like
a modulatory effects were two things
that I learned recently from from
another talk by Matthew was that it
actually seemed to be important for
driving a primary sensory response did
these experiments where they were using
they were behind limb or whisker sensory
drive of dinner
coming to layer one and if they block
that the neuron didn't respond to the
sensory stimulus which is we just sort
of turning the whole thing upside down
how do you what do you so so there is
some of that and lucy palma had a nice
paper in that and obviously what I have
not talked about at all here is
inhibition right and so the one of the
reasons we did this cracking experiment
was because one of the earth but Adam
did this experiment was because we
hypothesized that even more interesting
than the tuft input would be the tuft
inhibition that very few near glia form
cells can aboard a calcium spike and
then the formation of a person or not
right and so Matthew had shown some data
about that with in Lucy's paper right
but I am not so sure how that would look
like in v1 because in our hands it
didn't work
all right let's thank Costa
[Applause]